Speaker 1: Ladies and gentlemen, it's time
for the Friday mailbag.
You can email in to info at David Pakman dot
com.
Sometimes in addition to emails will feature
a tweet, a Facebook message, a YouTube comment.
Something else.
And I want to start today with a Facebook
message.
And one of the things every once in a while
I try to do, it's a very dangerous thing to
do, is a very fraught thing to do.
I will try to engage with a troll or just
a nut.
And last time I did this, it was an anti-vax
person.
And I actually said, hey, let's let's talk
to them, let's figure out how they came to
believe, the things they believe.
And I asked some questions and it was all
very weird and it went nowhere and we learned
very little.
I tried again the other day.
This is someone that send sending a message
via Facebook.
Stanley said, We found fraud attached to you.
You need to come clean with your listeners
about your scam.
So I wrote back, Great.
Please send the information of fraud and we
will come clean.
No idea what you're talking about offhand.
So they write back and they say, I'm sending
it to the faculty license department.
What's that?
And then they said the FCC department.
To which I explained again, this is an experiment
to see where it goes.
I said, We aren't governed by the FCC.
The FCC doesn't govern the Internet.
Let us know the fraud so that we can investigate.
To which Stanley said, Yes, you are.
You're of course it's the wrong your your
broadcasting which fall in FCC regulations
and you're wrong.
You're a subscriber channel as well, which
falls into money's changing hands.
And I said, money's changing.
Hands is under the purview of the FTC, not
the FCC.
Can you let us know the fraud so we can investigate
and correct it?
To which I never heard back.
So another exercise in the futility of trying
to substantively engage with the trolls.
Next.
The email is from Patrick.
Patrick is very angry with me.
Patrick says, Hi, David.
I thought you were an independent thinker.
I can't understand you praising Biden.
He doesn't know who he is, where he is, or
who his wife is.
Surely, you know this man is a threat to our
country and should be impeached for the open
borders alone.
Now, remember, there has been essentially
no change in border policy between Trump and
Biden.
Just.
We've stopped pretending that we're building
a wall.
That's the difference.
Also, I'm sure you know, because you are smart
that he is being used as a puppet for Obama,
rice and clain, very obvious actual people
running the country.
You are too young.
But the Biden family has been corrupt over
40 years and should be prosecuted.
Funny you never talk about the Biden laptop.
You are better off supporting Bernie Sanders.
Good luck.
So this is like it's got to be presented without
comment because there's about a dozen things
in there that don't make any sense.
But this is someone who believes.
That they know a lot and that they're really
smart and this is what we're up against.
How do you talk sense into someone like Patrick
or DL?
I don't know.
They signed their email deal.
Even though it came from Patrick, it's very
difficult to do.
Dale wrote in and said, Ouch.
David, you just called Native Americans, American
Indians.
Ouch.
So, listen, first of all, I didn't call them
that.
I was reading poll results and the poll referred
to American Indians and Alaska Natives.
Okay.
I use whatever term I understand to be the
correct term.
There was a time about a decade ago when it
was wrong to say American Indian, and you
were only supposed to say Native American.
Now, if you Google it increasingly, what you
find is that either term is appropriate Native
American or American Indian.
I have no preference one way or the other.
I'm just using the terms that are being determined
to be appropriate.
But I was literally reading a poll.
It wasn't a term I came up with.
Dale So see if you can relax a little bit
on that.
Lisa wrote in about watering times.
We talked about restrictions on when you're
allowed to water your lawn in different places.
And Lisa said, David, on the bonus show, you
talked about water use restrictions.
You may find it interesting to know that in
New Mexico, where it is hot and dry in the
summer, we have restrictions on the time of
day during which you are allowed to water
your lawn or outdoor plants due to the rapid
rate of evaporation during peak daylight hours,
which leads to water waste.
That makes a lot of sense.
And I know so little about this that I didn't
realize that some of the restrictions are
based on that.
But that makes a lot of sense.
And many such examples of people writing in
with comments like Lisa's Josh wrote in about
my interview with Republican Mike CARGILE,
and Josh said, Hey, David, how do we know
Mike CARGILE isn't the demon possessed one?
Prior to your interviews with him?
I didn't believe in demon possession, but
surely a demon possessed person would sound
exactly like Marky Mark.
Mike CARGILE Where do they find these people?
It is beyond me.
That interview with Mike CARGILE triggered
such a reaction from the audience.
If you haven't seen it, check it out.
He tells us who he believes are the demon
possessed people.
It's mostly blacks and Jews that he names,
which I pointed out to him.
It's a wild interview and it is shocking that
folks like this exist.
It really is.
It was eye opening.
Eye opening, for lack of a better term.
Mika wrote in and said, Hey David, I was thinking
about the story that Fred Trump was humored
into believing he still ran the Trump organization
when he had Alzheimer's.
How he went to the office every day to sign
blank papers and talk to a decoy secretary.
Not now knowing that Donald Trump kept those
classified documents, argued they belonged
to him, refused to give them back, even kept
some of them in his desk.
It's almost like props to play president on
top of all the rightful president stolen election
future reinstatement nonsense.
The parallel is amusing how much of the narrative
is grift and how much is delusion?
I used to think all grift, but I'm not sure
anymore.
Regards Mika.
Yeah, it's a good question.
I made this analogy earlier in the week.
The idea of Trump.
In a sort of Truman Show similar to his own
father when his father had Alzheimer's.
At this point, I don't even pretend to know.
I genuinely don't know how much is grift and
how much is delusion.
But it seems as though it seems as though
it's not 100% either.
It's some mix of the two.
Um.
I got an email about Latin texts.
David I heard your explanation of why Latin
X is imposed by white progressives and that
it is not used by Latino and Latina people.
Well, that may be the case within your circles.
The use of the ending with X is a way for
queer folk of romantic languages to express
and address each other.
You can see that in the U.S. with the onset
of an X to replace Mr. and Mrs..
Full disclosure, I am a queer, white progressive.
However, within my social media circles and
physical spaces, people of all origins Filipino,
European, South America, Latin is commonplace
because even Latino Latina is exclusive.
I would be curious if you have any statistical
data to back up your view on the term.
I can only speak from my experience.
Yeah.
I mean, when you actually look at surveys
of Latinos, for example, there's a 2019 survey,
national survey of Latinos found only 3% of.
And again, here you can use whatever term
you want to use.
Hispanics.
Latinos.
Only 3% of Hispanics Latinos have ever, ever,
ever used the term Latin X.
Ever 3% of Latinos.
The League of United Latin American Citizens
announced in 2021 they're going to stop using
Latin X because almost all Latinos don't like
it and don't use it.
So it is widely documented that almost no
actual Latino folks use Latin.
By the way, you should see there's this whole
other thing.
I don't even know that I want to get into
this, but.
There's this whole other thing where.
In Spanish words are gendered in that, for
example, if we talk about the word friends,
which the singular is amigo, okay, the plural
would be amigos or amigas.
If you say amigos, it's either a group of
male friends or a mixed group.
Men and women.
If you say Amigas with an A, it's understood
that it's a group of female friends.
This is this is the language.
This exists in, you know, friendship, that
this is the way it is in Spanish.
There's a new thing that has come up, which
is they replace instead of an O or an E. The
neutral.
I'm sorry, I just said that wrong.
Instead of an over and a you instead use an
E. So instead of Amigos or Amigas, it's a
me.
Yes.
And it is another thing which.
I don't do, and which is similar to Latin
acts that has started to sort of pervade the
language.
And anyway, maybe a topic for another day.
But there is my data.
Those two studies that I cited.
Next email from Sonia.
Sonia is really angry that I said I'm not
a cat guy.
It's not a big deal.
Some people aren't badger people.
Some people are into rhinos.
Some people are against HIPA.
I'm sorry.
Against hippos.
Sorry.
Now I got confused.
Sonia says, David, sir.
Love the show.
Proud subscriber.
You're an educated, articulate and astute.
You are educated, articulate and astute.
It's refreshing to watch your show and know
without a doubt that like minded progressives
still exist.
But I lost some respect for you when you recently
said you don't like cats.
There is a rule among cat lovers that says
if you meet a person who doesn't like cats,
run the other way.
I ascribe to this in my personal relationships,
but it will certainly not deter me from your
show.
You may think of me as a crazy cat lady.
She says she's 60, but I've loved cats and
all animals my entire life.
You're a father now.
You never know what surprises are in store.
I hope that one day you will be blessed with
the love of a cat.
Listen, this is not.
I don't hate cats.
I don't advocate violence against cats.
I'm just not a cat guy.
You know?
I like dogs.
I like, you know, I like zebras.
I don't know.
I'm just not a cat guy.
It's not a big deal.
And no offense to anybody that owns cats.
Jared said, Hey, David wanted to message you
to say thanks for your finance section on
your website.
I picked up a couple of the books.
I'm in my final semester of college.
Don't know much about finance, but the selection
you provided looked perfect.
Just wanted to say thanks.
Yeah.
Listen, if you want my list of recommendations
for personal finance books, you can find it
at David Pakman dot com slash finance.
Many such people have found it interesting.
Jonathan wrote in and Jonathan says, Hey,
David, you mentioned on a call that colleges
are prepared to pay handsomely for conservatives
like Ben SHAPIRO, but not for progressives.
That doesn't fit with the image of colleges
being heavily skewed to the left.
You know, postmodernist, Marxist, blah, blah.
What have I missed yet?
Listen, without delving at all into the academic
biases of colleges, what I can tell you is
most of the speakers that go to college campuses
and are paid are paid by groups, not by the
college itself.
It's not like the Department of Poly Sci pays
for Ben SHAPIRO to speak at a school and the
on campus.
Right wing groups are way better funded.
You know, there's these groups, Students for
Liberty, and I'm making that up.
There's a dozen or so groups.
The groups are way better funded on the right
than on the left.
And so that's why, in my experience, the money
is way better for right wing campus speakers
than for left wing campus speakers.
My experience, my experience, and I'm glad
to be pointed in a different direction.
You can email in info at David Pakman dot
com if you have something to say.
And remember 919 September 19th, we have a
fantastic one day membership special that
we will be doing.
If you have been thinking, maybe I'll get
a membership, I don't know.
Sounds interesting.
Get on my newsletter at David Pakman dot com.
And then on the Monday of September nine,
on the morning of September 19th, you will
get a beautiful email telling you how to sign
up at a historically humiliatingly low price.
All right.
See you then.
More on today's Boston.